hey everyone of interest infinity war
has been in our lives for a month or so
and many of us are still trying to
process all those huge game changers and
you guys have been reaching out to us
with some lingering questions that you
still have after the movie so this
episode we thought we'd do a Q&A to do
our best to answer all of your questions
Q&A Q&A Q&A first welcome to new
rockstars news everyone it's our deep
dive into all the biggest stories from
this week so in addition Julien this
infinity to our Q&A we're also gonna
talk about ant-man and the wasp and this
news about the walking dead without Rick
Grimes and the Harley Quinn animated
series the daredevil season 3 on Netflix
and more topics I'm Erik Voss joining me
at this table are there's a Sam over
here thank you for having me hi I'm
Philip and we're here to help we're
gonna get started with your big
unanswered questions from of interest
infinity war and yeah as I said we're
gonna do a Q&A we're gonna read the
tweets and comments that you guys have
been so awesome to write for us thank
you so much thank you I actually get a
lot of DMS from people who ask questions
and after the first two I got too
nervous so this is a good episode we're
gonna go deep into it alright Oh Jeremy
Hawkins tweeted us asking about when
spider-man saves Iron Man from call
obsidian early in the movie Iron Man
asks where it came from and spider-man
says the future maybe that's what some
people heard that's what I heard we this
is a short answer we just want to clear
this up right away because a lot of you
have been asking us about this he does
not say the future what does he say
field trip field trip he says field trip
cuz he's on a field it sounds like
future a little bit it took me a couple
times like re-watch in the movie but hey
spider-man comments been around for so
long it could be they could dabble with
the time travel story if they want to
they'll be kind of cool for old Peter
and young Peter to come together I'm
just thinking up in the comics yeah he's
like so like you kind of hate to do this
oh and he has a Christmas movie
experience whole life over again ya know
I mean it's definitely field trip but
hey it's sense there's plenty of time
travel in this movie I understand why
you thought you heard that you know who
could be from the future go to Eric's
real quick look at this so cool all
right let's move on to the next question
it's a lot of you guys been asking a
bunch of you guys actually asked is this
one a keeper or equipped Ryan burns and
Bruce Bruce de bas you guys were asking
what were the Guardians doing before
infinity war sleeping sleeping hanging
out stealing people and then taking
their money being scoundrels out yes
space pirates space cowboys the at the
beginning of the movie what are they
doing right they're just responding to a
distress call hoping to get money out of
this out of state of people and like
feeling slack mainly member their ship
yeah stealing from them and that's what
they were doing at the beginning of vol
2 you know they were taking a gig
basically go watch Firefly those
episodes or what they were doing and
just hold up little pictures of the
actors faces it's like no that's rock
let's move on to another question
Alex VC and Manu Spanos spin Oz wanted
to know could Thanos just have created
more planets to spread out the resources
instead of killing half the universe
with cancer Alex yes absolutely yes
imagine wishing arm he could do whatever
he wants but I feel I do like that they
grounded it and the fact that he is
basically he's basing off of what
happened to his planet and he didn't
have magic wishing arm as far as we know
or I had an idea of using that to like
wean down the population of Titan
instead he was like we should just
randomly execute people he's like it's
not from what he from his point of view
he says this isn't the best but it's
random it's like we tried to make this
as fair as possible yeah it's never
gonna be fair but they try to make as
fair as possible so he just applies that
to the whole universe and the only
problem is he says half of all life so
what does that mean does that mean half
of all plant and animals so does that
mean that all sentient life or anything
that's taking up resources yeah but I
mean if you you could argue that like
plants use up carbon dioxide and that's
a reason so but they create oxygen like
there must be something where you're
like a net drain on the world like us
the same biology there's consumers and
there's producers right an ecosystem so
anything is a consumer maybe if you
wanted to go deep like sometimes when
you plant large crops of corn they can
sometimes or or cotton has been known to
like kind of like suck up all the
nutrients from like certain crops so you
can't really plant anything there for a
while so it ruins it so maybe that's
seen as I'm just saying when you say
half of all life you're just kind of
taking the whole thing and just
shrinking it down so you still have the
same problem just at a smaller scale
yeah I totally hear what you're saying
like yeah he if you think about this
hard enough he can feasibly do anything
when you're like God over the universe
it may be just the snap is simpler and
quicker and he's thinking of like what
something I can do real fast for like
the brief amount of time I may be able
to have all stones you should just put
like balloons and all our stomachs and
then we eat half as much or something
you know plants with something yeah be
cute but it's not perfect if you really
want to start poking holes it's not
perfect he's a main Iza he's a maniac
and it's more exciting it's exciting to
have a villain wants to kill half of
people that's but like it wouldn't be
that exciting to see him like gradually
build another half of the universe maybe
he felt that those would be
overpopulated - yeah what both problems
will eventually return yeah but I guess
one also that version does have more
problems eventually right to increase
the size of every planet well slowly
they're gonna like crash into each other
you know like right now everything's
kind of in the state of homeostasis and
if you did have way more land or
something or like literally you would
have to double size the planet is what
this person's suggesting the impact of
that on the rest of the galaxy would be
very destructive there's just a lot of
like massive it had to be done make the
universe bigger yeah
well this actually brings us to our next
question asked by Kahlil and a bunch of
you guys if they aniseh snap randomly
picked half the population to fade away
how could Doctor Strange be sure that
Stark would survive that seemed to be a
big part of his agenda right like how
would he know and I guess the real
question is if dr. trains could fast
forward time to see all these different
14 million different possibilities did
that ability allow him to look beyond
his own fading away and that he has like
an omniscient view of what happens in
the timeline events or can he only see
up to the point of his death
the eye of agamotto has not shown that
it's like specifically attached to the
person wheeled in it right and he's
really looking through its eye so it can
see probably beyond his own dead they
failed and in Doctor Strange I'm
assuming that might have included you
know his own death and he could stay see
beyond that so I do think he can see
beyond that the question is can he see
based on the number of realities that he
saw this one were the exact people that
got killed were were the same ones in
other words Tony Stark did he know that
Tony was gonna die I think it might
sound like impossible when you think
well you'll you have 14 million versions
you've seen right 14 million he's over
14 million yeah but if you randomized
let's let's even just say earth for a
second every single person has a one at
a two a chance right so then if he
needed to be this exact arrangement of
everyone on earth then you have to
multiply each one of those one of the
two chances and it'd have to be this
exact one so pretty quickly he would
exceed 14 million realities that he
would have had to have checked but
that's not important actually because
you know Sam and we aren't helping the
world in any way really but definitely
not in this scenario so he doesn't need
to care about that he probably did go
forward enough to see including
randomizations of the important players
like Tony Stark like Black Widow right
like okay in this scenario it's
randomized and takes you know Tony and
it leaves
cap and it takes you know I was mess of
his name but spider-man's friend because
I was yeah but like whatever like he
knows based on the important players I
would think which ones need to go so
this was the reality where everything
lined up perfectly maybe also that punch
from Star Lord that he allowed to happen
again is because in the version where he
gets punched it's this exact people that
get snapped out yeah
and I'm willing to say I don't know for
sure if it was random by Thanos I know
he did say it was random it seemed like
you're flipping a coin by you're cool I
think there's a version of this where
yeah we'll see Thanos like wanted to
leave certain people behind and you know
I we just don't know for sure
that was that's kind of cool like
subconsciously there I think this that
whole confrontation maybe wasn't to get
the glove off till I can get rid of the
gauntlet maybe he was setting up the
necessary things to change their houses
mine down the line that he he showed him
enough of like this is what you did to
star Lord this is the kind of
philosophies that we're talking about
and showing this is what Tony's willing
to do to stop you and that maybe there's
like anyways it's just planning ideas in
his head and maybe that gives enough
time to be exposed to the soul stones or
maybe alter his physiology there's a
bunch of fun ideas that you can throw
out there but maybe he did know exactly
who was going to maybe if he did this
this and this Tony being close to death
meant that for some reason he didn't
have to die in the snap that seems
unfair honestly could he just stabbed
him in the stomach and he was bleeding
out on an alien planet maybe put him out
of his misery yeah anyways there's fun
ideas there but like maybe he didn't
know and maybe subconsciously
subconsciously he did choose to save the
specific people because they could stop
him in the future yeah who knows well
another pattern that you guys picked up
on in the movie just kind of a detail
that stood out is they're in a deep hoc
asked about this and a couple others
reached out as well what is the
significance of the number 17 in the
movie and is there significance I think
you're referring to there's a moment
earlier in the film when Tony Stark's
summons the iron spider armor and it's
from like 17 a it's from storage bin 17
and then later in the movie black
panther tells instructs the wakandan
people to open up the shield at number
17 or something like that but yeah 17
does show up twice yeah when I saw this
in the movie I was thinking oh maybe
it's because like this is the 17th MCU
movie but it's not it's either the 18th
or the 19th there's no way to know yeah
there's no way to count
I pretty sure Thor Ragnarok was the 17th
if not a Black Panther was a 17 so maybe
it could be like 17 preceding films or
or you know or there's 17 in the comics
somewhere I mean they were shooting it
in 17 you know yeah 2017 lots of
virginity 17 like a lot of things maybe
of maybe Peter 17 at this point because
he's still in high school maybe not
waited yet oh that could be it it's not
the most exciting answer but yeah
there's a Tim Tim Gunn actually it works
the number 12 actually shows up a lot in
screenwriting and scripts because the
number 12 and when you write it out as a
word is the longest one syllable number
word that is of the highest number so
after that you think like 13 14 those
are the numbers when you write it that
actually takes longer in movie scripts
when you're writing them out you write
it out as the word you don't write the
digits 40 yeah 40 oh yeah or 50 60 70
yeah yeah well then I don't know maybe
when you're trying to get with it like
it's too big like how many kids did you
have 40 I could take it up with okay
moving onto the next question
venom lover asked us why doesn't dr.
strange use the time stone more in his
fight against Thanos and I think this is
just a general question a lot of people
are having any time you bring in time
travel into a movie it's basically you
now have like a god power that you
really could use for all kinds of like
powerful ways like you know simply he
could rewind the time stone to tell the
star-lord not to punch Stannis in the
face they get the gauntlet off of them
you know you can rewind the clock
further and further and just slip
disposal but why do we think that they
didn't explore more of these and
infinity war you did see him try and it
went poorly immediately like he tried to
use it against them all and immediately
he got choked out and the stone almost
got taken and that's actually how he got
kidnapped because he tried to stop and
use it and so that he already knew that
probably wasn't the best idea also 14
million times there's probably a time in
there that he tried it at least once
maybe and probably a couple to me least
twice maybe that's my idea there is just
the same thing you have to remember that
he saw different timelines if using the
time stone had been necessary if it had
been the one time is when I tweaked a
little bit and just this thing he would
have done it this is the he did he did
the ultimate cheat with the time stone
he figured out how they win right like
that's like the biggest why would he
also do it to be
to mess with call obsidian further
something like he doesn't need to eat it
exactly as much of it as he needed yeah
and I think that's what it is it's like
what is the most valuable way to use a
time stone within the world of this
movie like I know in the movie Doctor
Strange Mordo said that the time stone
could be used in all kinds of disastrous
ways animals get made and pebbles get
eaten oh boy what anything why didn't he
try that what do you know it's yeah yeah
it's the same reason like when you watch
the third Harry Potter movie wyden
Hermione is the time turner to go back
and kill Voldemort like it's it's just
the movie starts to lose its meaning
that's a real thing that people have a
completely Oh time Turner confuse the
hell out of people on leaky cauldron in
a Potter net yeah you if you follow that
it's kind of like every movie has plot
holes right and if you shine a light on
any part of the movie yeah you can ask
questions endlessly but the point is as
you're watching the movie does this
bother you in the moment as you're
watching the scene then yeah it's kind
of a plot hole if it's something to
where it's like days later you're like
wait a minute that doesn't totally make
sense you could say that Burtt literally
any movie that's it all your favorite
movies have enormous plot holes on them
I'm uh I'm fine with the amount of times
they use the time stone actually I read
this one thing online about when Thanos
comes to Titan the first person he
talked to his doctor strange and he's
kind of almost sounds annoyed with him
like not then he's like oh you're trying
to kill the universe you know it's like
he's annoyed because he probably had
this same conversation fourteen million
times so where are we you're home and
it's just like yes it's my home it's
like so he's just kind of waiting he's
just waiting for this to finally have
one let's go back but yeah he fights
with his girlfriend or like no you're
all right I was wrong but like it was
kind of funny that like he sounds
annoyed more so than he did in previous
scenes because he already went through
this and he's saying the things that he
needs to say to make this work yeah so
basically he doesn't want to use up all
the batteries in the time stone exactly
blaze
next question asked by at Gabe mango on
Twitter and Aaron Kim
one of our YouTube comments on our
breakdown what happens to red skull
after Thanos gets the soul stone like
will we ever see red skull again that's
because he had been banished there
specifically with the idea that he would
have a stone within sight that he could
never have because he never loved anyone
so that's done so either it's you know
he's he's part of his torture that the
tesseract had signed to him is and then
he stays there for eternity or what's
kind of fun is if you go to the comic
book route everybody all the villains
always survive stuff and then they come
back yeah and so that's a very fun idea
because you know they have other Captain
America movies that they might want to
make like it it's so rare that villains
get to come back in the MCU it'd be
really cool to get Red Skull back almost
cut him red stone maybe so maybe he just
walks off into a cave he grabs Gamora
kimura and maybe like a puppet tool and
she's like hey good more how you doing
and other people were gross online but I
was like what if she just has the best
friend he could just talk about he's
like hey yeah it's not great but I mean
it shows he's so he can't really
complain turns like tan yeah you could
just be a stone keeper as he always was
but now he has to be like Danis is
Butler and like polished the gauntlet
like I keep this stone do you have
anyone you love you could sacrifice like
ya know
basically he's unemployed if you're
hiring red skulls looking guys alright
next question
Isaac Thurmond on Instagram actually
reached out to me and yeah Isaac
Thurmond a bunch of people actually have
been asking this question and we've
addressed some of the videos did Hulk
refuse to come out in this movie because
he was afraid of Thanos or because he
remembers how much earth hates him and
before we get too far into this we might
be doing an actual video about this
subject exactly but what are you guys
thoughts on this subject yeah you guys
he got hit so hard that he's calm now
he's smacked the anger right out of that
like yeah basically right like he like
is no longer like mad he's just like I
like the idea and this is something that
some
other people were talking about I like
the idea that he's fed up that he's just
like no I'm the one that gets hit I'm
the one who has to do the heavy lifting
always I'm the one everybody hates I'm
done I'm all done like I'm tired of like
a guy I tried one more time to be the
good guy I get my ass handed to me and I
still lose like it's like I'm done I
don't want to do I don't want to be
called out just to help you every single
time no one and hope is at least
perceptive enough to know that everyone
hates him like everybody hates him or is
scared of him and like they has he can
go have a talk with scarlet witch r.i.p
if i could be like like don't let the
fear rule you anyways basically i phi in
his shoes if he's acting kind of like a
child i would be tired i would be just
tired of all this in me he might not be
smart enough to totally perceive how big
of a threat this actually is if he does
not help so real time per second have
either of you guys ever been beaten up
no I tried my best not emotionally one
time I got punched by his guy Leonard
you're watching sixth grade and he had a
big bruise but I actually do remember
thinking like man I'm gonna mess him up
so bad the next time I see him he just
like like kind of like sucker-punched me
so I'm gonna mess him up so bad and I
never went back to that spot in front of
the school school and I think that's
kind of where he's at where he's kind of
like standing right there it's kind of
like yeah you know what I don't need to
expose myself to the exact same
ass-whipping that I already received
yeah I also just think it's more
interesting to see Bruce Banner with
performance anxiety which isn't
something it's got the reverse of what
we normally use late last year from Zoll
89 if groots arm was the storm breaker
does that mean Groot was worthy to wield
the weapon have an interesting
metaphysical question can I do the same
rules apply to things once I become part
of them well so if you were made of
spareribs
question here is do we hit know that the
exact same rules apply to Stormbreaker
oh yeah that is a good question I don't
know we didn't see anyone else pick it
up or like enchanted in any way yeah
like just been forged maybe it's like
you can be dirty dirty and still pick
this thing up yeah danos didn't get laid
out totally when he got an axe to the
chest he was still standing and when
loki gets it he's pinned to the ground
permanent he'd probably starve to death
if he put him there right yeah it wants
to be on the ground but then also then
like how worthy is a coffee table in
Thor 2 he puts it on a coat rack and he
walks away from here so the most noble
coat rack in the land so maybe it's a
little bit more like Groot is a bit of a
surface I think once his arm gets
severed that is no longer part of him if
there is another sentient Groot hold but
hold it up before his arm lifts it yeah
I guess it's in the process of becoming
Stormbreaker in that moment yeah if he's
wielding it truly he is maybe not all
the magics there yet yeah yeah
maybe you can't pick it up now actually
no that's a fun theory because the
Lightning doesn't start coming off of it
until Thor like wakes up and pulls it to
him like it's still just two pieces of
metal they're very thick you're not
really sure it may be you either that's
what it is in the comic didn't really
say what it wasn't this it could be that
but they think there's no magic that's
like activated until he calls it over
and it's or one more question I think we
have time for a bunch of people been
asking this but Alex Vega wanted to know
why would hella call Odin's Infinity
Gauntlet fake I guess I was in Thor
Ragnarok if an infinity war we learned
that the real one was just made
relatively recently by Eitri before the
events of the movie I think that's a no
I think that well maybe hoops but I
think it could be just a
misunderstanding of what her meaning of
fake is not that doesn't look like the
real one it could be like this thing I
can tell is not would not be able to
wield the stone yeah this jewelry looks
fake you know you can just feel like oh
it's not this isn't real it is unlikely
like it the proper whatever they make
the gauntlet out of there and they Forge
would be obviously like oh that thing
could hold could wield the stones this
is made out of literally
any other metal that isn't powerful
enough I mean we saw the dad metal
crumpled right when they get used so
maybe it's just an assessment
immediately of like there's no way that
would be the gauntlet if there wasn't
yeah I also just think it's like like
many things in thro Ragnarok it's a joke
it's a it's a meta thing that's really
just meant for us you know fans who have
watched the original Thor the first Thor
and there was like the gauntlet in the
background and they didn't really know
how the gauntlet would be used in the
future the MCU and I think they're just
doing that to kind of close that loop
and give them a twank they're like we're
aware that there is a goofy gauntlet in
this vault and we're just telling you
right now fans if they not the guy in
the plot hole video I did a couple weeks
ago though that was a big one it was
like how was that there how it thoughts
aged also doesn't make a lot of sense in
that movie based on like in the movie
you see the big war between the frost
giants and as Guardians that happens
they get baby Loki and baby Thor and
they grow up together and they never are
in these big battles on earth that's
what they establish and then there's a
book later in the movie that says like
Oh remember when they used to do all
this on it doesn't make any sense cuz
he's now a young man after a couple
thousand years so it doesn't make a lot
of sense so that the early Thor movie is
what I'm saying don't always follow
logic and they don't make a lot of sense
they just wanted to make it look cool
and that was a very cool Easter Egg to
hide there yeah later on oh oh here's
what's interesting that movie those
movies are were heavily designed by the
writers of infinity war mm-hmm because
they did the dark world and then they
did not do Ragnarok but they were on the
phone with Tycho saying what the hell
are you doing but they so they actually
probably did have a little bit of like
oh like that they did have to figure out
how are we gonna make this work now yeah
I think the tyka would be in general
with Ragnarok had kind of a loose
interpretation of how the the timeline
of events worked like there was a
deleted scene it was gonna feature yondu
in it when yondu of course died at the
end of volume 2 accordion so I think
he's just exist in the world it's
somewhere and I don't think he was
really thinking about other than like
there's circumstances of how Hulk ended
up there and how Thor ended up where he
was I don't know if the script is really
that focused on fitting in the
continuity of MCU but those were the
questions we have time for and thank you
all so much for said
your thoughts and keep sending them you
know if we didn't answer your question
here there is a very good chance we will
be answering it in a future video on its
own you'll get the star treatment where
you know one of us will be screaming at
you in front of a blue screen after all
the research I've done for it
and we keep those questions coming we
look forward to hearing from you all and
thank you again but let's move on to
this week's trivia question heck yeah a
heck yeah
and we have our cards here in infinity
war what humorous phrase is written on
the sign in the restaurant in Scotland
that Scarlet Witch and visions stand
outside okay all of our answers are in
the bucket here later in the show we'll
reveal the answer to the trivia question
and the closest answer as decided by our
judge will do our signup goodbyes at the
end of video the loser will have to do
something challenging as always it'll be
fun
but let's move on before we continue
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe a
quick update from some of the news this
week since its Disney rockstars news we
want to cover everything for you so you
don't have to go to all the other dumb
sources ok the upcoming Harley Quinn
animated series will reportedly feature
actress Kaley Cuoco
from the Big Bang Theory ok a cuoco
could be voicing Harleen Quinzel herself
or a different character various
actresses have played harley over the
years of course there was Margot Robbie
and Suicide Squad and our Arleen Sorkin
voiced her in the Batman in the in
animated series other names on the new
series patch lists include n Tara Strong
Arlene yeah early it's working did one
and Tara Strong has done and another
other versions there's been a lot of
different ones over the years but other
names on the cast list included alan
tudyk and tony hale alan tudyk has done
voice of the flash in the oh yeah he's
amazing yeah Tony Hale from veep in the
rest of development ok everyone a new
trailer for ant-man and the wasp dropped
this week it's on the shorter side
shorter hair with a few new shots of the
villain ghost and a that's a woman who
can face shift through solid surfaces
very cool and there's some banter
between scott hank and hope
interestingly the trailer ends with
Scott Lang saying oh also we got to save
the world that's major
can't forget that
now sure that could just be a joke about
how every superheroes task is pretty
much to save the world but in the
context of the ending of infinity war
Scott might not be too far off so how
exactly will ant-man steepleconnect to
those events it's pretty clear that
ant-man the wasp will at least be set
before infinity war it's just not likely
that Scott and the rest would care that
much about ghosts and silly car chases
and shrinking down buildings into
luggage if half of the freaking world
had just been snapped out of existence
right like that's an apocalyptic
situation civilized society would be
losing their minds but it is still
possible that the ending of ant-man the
wasp could tie into infinity war like
we've speculated the pass of a final
scene of the movie or maybe a
post-credits scene could feature
characters in Scotts world suddenly
interesting element from ant-man has
that he has contributed to the MCU is
the quantum realm remember that's a
subatomic dimension that exists beyond
time and space it's where Janet Van Dyne
the original original wasp is still
missing the movie will focus on their
search for her now access to a dimension
beyond time and space sounds like it
could give ant-man
and the wasp a special edge against
Thanos and Avengers 4 if that ends up
going that way or if you believe in the
theory that the characters have faded
away at the Infinity war were actually
just transported to another parallel
dimension maybe the quantum realm could
serve as a way you can go between those
dimensions allowing a mantle like rescue
people and bring them back what do you
guys think what are some ways that like
ant-man could connect to infinity war
can you match and if that's like the the
Tony has about saving the universe like
oh we gotta save the world to like you
get outside and you see somebody like
sweeping up like a bunch of stuff off
the ground you're like Oh little dark he
just he's just joking and shrinking and
having a great time flying on with a
with wasp its I'm hoping that we that's
post-credit I'm hoping that the movie is
contained enough that we can just still
get a story and it doesn't have to
literally end with that no it's
definitely gonna be yeah I'm gonna put
money down on that right here I'm
announcing it get ready 6 bucks
now the question will it be comedic will
it be dark like what daughter's name
Cassie Cassie
[Laughter]
or will it be kind of a joke like maybe
some one of his buddies
Michael piñas character could be fade
away as he's telling the story bit away
maybe like Hank I think that would that
would add some stakes for hope
I mean not that she would need any but
something that would have personal stake
in that so yeah she's motivated to join
the Avengers and come help out feel like
that Scott Yeah right he could dust out
maybe but we have seen some onset stuff
with him and the other Avengers so maybe
it's hard to it's really hard to know
cuz you hear all these things of like
some people are confirmed for interest
for who have faded away yeah but I do
like your idea like if he is gonna help
I hope it's something specific to a
man's powers and not that thing where
you kind of just like packs a wallop
sometimes I don't know where like that
yeah that's a very basic usage of in
that I almost feel like include them or
not like you don't have to include them
if you do find a clever way to use them
and I think we all know it's getting
small enough to get behind the stones
and pushing this or crawling in this
year and I'm super excited about the
Cointreau just because it seems so
cosmic for a movie that seems anything
but that seems pretty practical and like
rounded like going into this whole other
realm that seems almost dr. strange Ian
I would love to see if that like if
there's some kind of very specific way
that he can connect with the people have
faded away through the quantum realm
don't know that I buy that because the
quantum realm is supposed to be this
idea of like beyond subatomic links so
it's it's in existence and we're just
going to the most basic forms of our
existence but then it just something
about that logics I see that line down
of like shrinking I don't see why the
alternate realities we're gonna have
their own quantum realm but it's a
circle it like it funnels down and all
of reality is within a circle that
creates a portal back and you know
there's another side that's how the
cornermen realm works in our world so if
the writers were good I feel like maybe
he shrinks down hit official theory he
shrinks down into the soul stone that'd
be kind of cool with whole worlds in
there and maybe we don't have a direct
way of like getting to it and that could
be a place that that could be a way that
he helps out because ant-man has shrunk
into cosmic level things in the comics
it's always been very cool the way they
played around with that kind of stuff
and I feel like that'd be a good way to
get him to help out
it's and a lot of people do believe that
that is where the souls of the people
who faded away or contain they're
contained within the soul stone that's
one idea that people have so maybe that
gives me sounds like people like and
want them to have a backup copy everyone
I just don't know that they're so like
even if it's their souls and what makes
them corporeal again that's a question
we all have ghosts get in line it's like
a it's like an assembly line it's like
skin soul scan it soul guys run away
quick because people are coming out
quick all right another interesting news
update to come out from this week guys a
set photo from Daredevils third season
on Netflix included a costume department
jacket with a logo showing a target
hinting to some of us that the villain
of that third season could be the
bullseye yes
bullseye is probably one of the more
well-known villains from daredevil in
the Marvel Comics right Colin Farrell
our buddy back here played a version of
bull's eye in the 2003 Ben Affleck
daredevil no one ever makes fun of of
course they explain in that does he did
he do that to himself hmm
no I've watched it recently hey doesn't
that scene this specific scene is when
he's like doing darts in a bar and then
he grabs a paper hook because someone
makes one of them he somehow flattens it
out by doing this and he he darts the
dude in the throat with it it's that's
cool whenever he moves his jacket
rattlesnake sounds come out of it
cigarette burner and a car said when he
was a baby because that's what I'm a bit
small yeah well there's your update on
daredevil season 3 okay everyone we just
learned that The Walking Dead's leading
man Andrew Lincoln who plays Rick Grimes
will not continue on the series
throughout season 9 currently he is
planned for a six episode arc in season
9 after which he will depart from the
series Lincoln is the only cast member
to remain on the show from its pilot in
2010
Chandler Riggs Carl was killed off this
past season and Lenny James Morgan
returned for the past few seasons he was
gone for a bit now he recently moved on
to fear The Walking Dead and really
after Andrew Lincoln the only cast
members left from season 1 are Norman
Reedus who plays Darryl and Melissa
McBride who plays Carol AMC is
reportedly in talks with Norman Reedus
to give him a race to 20 million dollars
to stay on the show throughout season 9
or you could cancel it or you could
cancel that's the that's kind of the
question now right because the death of
Carl was such a huge shocker to viewers
because Carl was really the future of
the storylines and Robert Kirkman's
comics he kind of becomes sort of what
seems like the the successor to lose
Rick would be an even bigger blow he
really is the heart of the series so I
mean he could say that maybe Daryl and
Carol and negan are certainly strong
supporting characters I would say having
watched all these episodes more than
once the way their characters have been
used in recent seasons it's kind of lost
some of the enthusiasm at least I have
had for them and in past seasons like 3
& 4 but I don't know do you guys think
there is a future for the show how what
could a future look like if Daryl's now
the leading man on the show or is it
really time to call it quits
whenever shows have made these kind of
tougher calls to try to keep going when
the lead actor leaves it's never they
don't last long they'll probably get
another season usually a Walking Dead is
the biggest show cables ever had period
forever and ever amen but like that you
can only keep going for so long and
since fan excitement for the show I
don't know specific numbers off the top
of my head of what kind of like
viewership they 17:17 million for the
negan glance ode it's dropped it's now
beneath 10 million viewers in episode 4
many of you season 8 but I started
really good anyway yeah that I wouldn't
see the show going much further but
again I am NOT the biggest fan of
Walking Dead so I do not know well let's
try to come up with a way that if the
show had to keep going because money
then I don't know that it's Norman
Reedus leading the same story again
right like right Andrew Lincoln did a
good job in his character
you know even in the comics like they
almost run out of stuff to where to take
his character he just becomes an old man
basically
some talks that maybe lauren cohan as as
Maggie could she could she's also her
contract has been kind of in question
whether she's gonna reach one these are
actors that want to have careers right
outside of just this one show which
especially you know engine Lincoln was
starting to age out of it I'm sure he
also is sick of having a beard yeah but
what is the version of this show that
say they were like okay we're gonna do a
hard pivot you know is there another
thing my gut always goes to there I know
that this is a story that's been told I
always really liked like military and
like like the White House version like
what what happened to the president what
happened to the vice president always
loved seen the institution's crumble
yeah I think it'd be interesting to
follow an institutional Darabont wanted
to do from the the guy in the tank from
the voice of Darth Maul in actual solo
yeah he they were gonna follow him in
season two as we know a little bit a
little bit it's tough right cuz fear The
Walking Dead already showed us a version
of like the earlier part of the timeline
right and they didn't show us they
showed us kind of what I think I'm
saying is like pretty common to see is
like the little band of military that's
always supposed to be like a Salvation
but then it ends up being corrupt kind
of thing but I think like what about
like a version of like Apocalypse Now or
something like a Colonel Kurtz figure
that's out there and like actually has
you know he he has sees himself as the
head of the government now because he's
the highest-ranking military official
and then like you know but he's also
corrupt and maybe other military people
have to take him out or something like I
don't know I could see some sort of
thing there but again I'm talking about
pretty hard for this that would have to
be a hard pivot I think there's a
version of this I could maybe and this
is probably what they would try to do if
Norman Reedus Reedus ended up taking up
the show it's basically have norman
radius radius rate Reedus as the leader
of the survivors of the Alexandria safe
zone and have the whisper storyline with
him and he has to deal with alpha and
all the characters who are connected
with the whisperers which doesn't sound
that exciting because really it's maybe
it's just a version of Dura we know is
from recent seasons where he's really
just been like running around the woods
grunting when also a storyline is not
it's not like there's one
crazy-cool thing that happens the show
could benefit from taking some creative
you know choices of making some creative
choices of their own and changing it up
a little bit but I mean if you have safe
bet for me you go with the fan favorite
character and that's Norman Reedus I
know that you you are right about ways
Darrell Darrell right
his current like situation the way he's
been portrayed but you could spend some
time like growing and making him
actually like develop more so I think
the show needs to be smaller like AMC if
you're looking for a way to save money
with this like season one just felt so
intimate and on a personal level like
the opening sequence which you know
pretty much adapted frame for frame from
Robert Kirkman's comics had like this 28
days later feeling to it and it felt
like yeah this is a very interesting
story now it just feels like post
apocalyptic politics in a way that
sometimes is interesting but overall
just feels like we're jumping around to
be plots and episodes with characters
that we aren't that excited about but I
think there's a way can make this work
instead of maybe doing eight episodes
and a tip so it's 16 versus oh you got
to fill up like maybe just have like a
six episode arc and maybe make that all
of season nine and if it does well make
it six great episodes and then decide
which characters you want to bring back
for season 10 which could be just
another six episodes if you decide to go
with that way yeah I think the biggest
issue of the show had is that and it had
to because of logic it's been on so long
they had to figure out how to deal with
walkers and they did
mm-hm and so the biggest threat the
titular threat of the show stopped
mattering right it was now the walkers
on the show are almost the idea of like
yeah Karl got in a car accident or
something right it's like this thing
that like if everything goes according
to plan you shouldn't even be worried
about the walkers and then oh no the dam
broke and he drowned in walkers like the
walkers have just become kind of
background set dressing yeah yeah like
like just like whoa this rock is
slippery uh like like that's what it
feels like to be attacked by Walker now
instead of that looming threat that
almost like Michael Myers represents
that it's like always right behind you
and you just don't know it so my
favorite moment of the show was when
they had no grounds like no nowhere to
be they were just camping mm-hmm and
it's like one of the most shocking
moments amazing season one is they
they're camping out Rick hasn't gone
back to them or or he
about something and they're just in the
middle of woods and they're sitting
around the campfire
and they just get overtaken about
Walker's know the camera pans around
there's a walker grilling a s'more
feeling like there's always one right if
they're talking bad about there's one
right behind but that feeling that the
Walker was always right behind you kind
of thing right and that's totally gone
so maybe if you put Daryl on the road
maybe they don't get that back yeah
going back to basics not a bad idea
yeah all right now let's move on to our
new rock stars news lightning round
you guys should tweet those questions
I'm gonna fire them at my co-host they
have to answer them as quickly without
hesitation as possible
starting with Sam hello at Olivia so mo
wants to know how does Sam get his hair
so great close-up if you have one
you check it out it's pretty gross up
close about a hair up there too much huh
there you go bumble and bumble you
usually it's a it's a matte finish you
can put that in your hair and you'll
look a lot better than me
bumble and bumble a bubble bubble yeah
it caught it's not news no Matt is a
matte finish Phillip at I want to say at
joven but it's not it's js0 v3n joven
yeah would why would Han keep the name
the Empire gave him it'd be like if
Nazis gave you your last name that's a
good question I mean I feel like a lot
of like but aside from that like it's
he's just your last name as a metaphor
for who you are right so it's kind of
like what would you change it to like
only and it's different in the military
like simple example my dad's last name
was voz growing up v OSS and then he
became a navy officer and then just his
drill sergeant all of his colleagues
started calling them vas and that's just
now our sexual family all these brothers
and their kids go by boats we go by yeah
just because it's the military but
honestly here's a in World answer if you
want one ever right it's I
you take what the people you hate the
most have branded you with and you use
it against them this is a reminder
claiming exactly and now it's your and
that is what my father lightning with
Eric at easy at Olivia Domo you got to
in here good job Olivia Elmo fear of
missing out Marvel character you relate
to or are similar to whoever character
you most similar to can the rest of us
answer this yeah I want I'll say my
answer I'm curious who are you guys
thing most similar to probably like
Jarvis before he becomes vision who's
just kind of like I know it all the time
he's always the last word yeah
the Ned and the guy in the chair playing
games and helping out in DC has arms no
I would say he's gonna which cuz you've
got over that accent the bows accent and
a question that we didn't have time for
that I thought was interesting I want
you guys to answer below who is the
better Han Solo Sam Phillip or Erik Sam
food looks the most like Alden
Ehrenreich hello right your old man
Harrison Ford in the force awakens yeah
that bitter thing I'm the most likely to
cheat liar steal so I feel like it's
like all of us together are half a man
I'd mostly I hate you know if you want
to throw that nice I look like Elton and
gang but also I'd be most likely to talk
to a dog for a long period of time so
that's always
as that bonus to me yeah and thank you
great and yeah thank you all for writing
your questions I keep them up and we'll
we'll get to them in future episodes but
now comes the time for our 15 second is
shout out to where each of us has 15
seconds to shout out plug or ramble
doubt anything we want to talk about Sam
well used to it is the beginning of
Pride Month so uh celebrate
appropriately be nice to each other and
have fun 15 seconds Oh Phillip go ahead
uh
it's the near time of VidCon alright so
get ready VidCon June 20th through 23rd
we're gonna be there plus mod so if you
want to meet us in person we're gonna
try to set up some sort of
meet-and-greet accept VidCon told us
that they don't have one space available
if you know where the clothes and then
host a meet-and-greet
we're gonna be giving away some sweet so
come find us because we will have cool I
almost gave away what it was we've had
cool stuff for you guys so find any of
us and we'll have some yeah and check
our social media feeds Sue's will be
maybe we'll do that thing I you throw
several thousands of dollars into a
placing cause an intentional mob that
was last year oops
for my 15 seconds out I want to shout
out someone who doesn't get enough love
Disney or oh right we gave you guys some
heat this time last year when Disney
fired the Lord and Miller directing team
and replaced him with Ron Howard but man
did Disney get it right this week with
the you know as you may have know ABC
cancelled Roseanne which is its current
number-one show not an easy thing to do
from a business perspective but you know
as someone who grew up with the show
Roseanne in the 90s and I liked the new
version of it the it's whatever your
politics are Roseanne Barr is not the
best person and she has Delvin some very
dangerous conspiracy theories
racism and in an anti-semitism and it's
not good for someone like that to have
such a huge platform and you know what
this isn't about freedom of speech if
you know if a network decides that
someone like that doesn't deserve to be
a millionaire that's in that network's
right to do that I think we're all
better off for it she can say anything
she wants on her Twitter or whatever her
own YouTube channel but we don't have to
let that person be super wealthy and
have such a huge voice in our society
and they can get there you know the
wrongs off other places but I think it's
we're better off for all of us this way
I think the world's a better place and
you know what everyone on that show is
at the top of their game they'll be able
to find work elsewhere I don't think any
of them are sweatin at that John Goodman
will be fine yeah yeah absolutely by the
way I just so no one lays into Eric I
totally agree with Eric Sam dick totally
agree with Eric our owners will have all
of us fired in our place
yeah well and finally let us return to
our trivia question that we asked
earlier remind everyone what it was
that's not a restaurant right the oh the
humorous phrase on the sign in the
scottish restaurant at Scarlet Witch and
vision were standing outside what did
the I'll not kind of get my rest day
okay so what did Sam say Sam said
ravioli ravioli give me the formuoli
some spongebob you know what's so weird
I knew it had to be from Sponge Bob
because it's just like the same nonsense
repeated again and again yes
ravioli ravioli give me the formuoli
Scottish restaurants Philip said wet
your willy here Scottish name and a
formula for the krabby patty that's what
that Eric said Shrek eats free Shrek his
life yeah Shrek eats free he's trying to
fall into your guest judge Aaron Paul
when what had the well I should say what
the correct answer is you don't get to
decide yet I win
well let's say what the answer is the
answer is we will deep fry your kebab
because it's a thing that's that where
they deep-fry everything
Bob's are Scottish deep fry anything so
you bring over a Greek kebab debrief
yes they do all right so you were saying
who is closest to me of course yes Trek
speaks in a Scottish accent
so yes it's yeah don't get three all
right well the winner will do our
good-byes first we're gonna quickly run
through some other news headlines we
don't have time for Phillip will read
each headline the loser me I'll make a
joke about it to cleverly riff on the
headline mm okay I'm not buying it I
think you'll love this hmm I should love
it go for it all right
in other news West world and x-men
starred James Marsden will star in a
live-action version of Sonic the
Hedgehog young I'm sure after watching
that movie we'll all want to be Cyclops
is at least gouge our eye out and leave
one eye audience please don't make it
look like Eric was doing something else
[Laughter]
other news solo writer Larry Kasdan said
he and Harrison Ford fought for Han Solo
to die in Return of the Jedi do not make
it sound like Eric is is feeling
something else
they the way they wanted him to die was
to have him he walk the plank Hey in
other news Tom Hanks said he almost made
a cameo in so low a Star Wars story as a
stormtrooper but that his schedule
did not line up something cool yeah
the young his character name would have
been captain Phillips because pirates do
that movie
sure job and also oh god there's two
more hey all right
Thor Ragnarok and Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom actor Jeff Goldblum is releasing
a jazz piano album
those are his chance movie yeah no
recent Jeff Goldblum so what I'm doing
is I have like the three different
categories of specifics and I'm trying
to connect the dots you ever hear a joke
explained to you before it's told it
makes it buzz just watch any one of my
videos already Morty you got this
jazz is music so old only dinosaurs
listen to it Sesame Street lost a
lawsuit against an upcoming Melissa
McCarthy movie the happy time murders
which features a gag about ejaculating
puppets
is there anything funny about that Eric
I guess they're not just stuffed with
stuff in
[Applause]
[Laughter]
time for goodbyes thank you guys for
watching this week's episode of new rock
stars news want to thank our hosts over
here on me at Sam basher you can follow
me there you check out my podcast only
stupid answers over here you got Eric
lost Eddie a Voss it's in the game and
over on the already I feel Melina add
fimo go check him out and that's the
only stop putting your name in the
teleprompter and episodes that you know
Tommy back though alright comment down
below and tweet at new rock stars like
this video share it around and subscribe
to the rock stars to check out more deep
dives into the stuff that you love we'll
see you guys next week bye oh my god I'm
gonna look make that look really can you
curse and I well I won damn it how do I
be funny
on the fly VidCon we're gonna raid you
one of your Airbnb where were you guys
gonna come out my [ __ ] nose